alright here we are at your innovation
event we're not on a field with a bunch
of sweatpants and cleats this is
extraordinary of Moynihan station the
destination for Fashion Week so who is
Nike today
well we're unveiling a whole new wave of
innovation from digital platforms our
Nike Plus app which is personalized
service for athletes incredibly exciting
to make it easy to get fit a real
important step for us a connected app
that actually allows you to have your
own personal store to get fit in terms
of what your personal goals are it's all
about personal service it's adapted for
you
and then we have a whole range of
innovation and projects across the
product spectrum from new forms of nike
air breakthroughs whole new forms of
Flyknit Nike Flyknit digital knitting is
taken to the next level and then we have
that in terms of digital we're often
confused because you were the first in
terms of the fuel band you stopped
producing it so many have said well
maybe connected Fitness isn't for Nike
yet you're leaning in in a big way
exactly how and is it your ties with
apple the Apple ties are one part of it
being more personal giving the athletes
an experience it's easier that's
connected that's simple that's more
personal it's really what's important
then why not have a band well the the
access to data and a dashboard is not
enough in our opinion it's part of the
process so people will be collecting
data with other devices that's just not
what we're doing we're not creating the
devices but the devices can be actually
input and they are that's an important
part of the experience an important
get more personal you mentioned flying
it last time we spoke it was the flying
it cleat that was your favorite flying
it clearly on the board what do you love
today you know what it's like asking me
my favorite child I can't pick one but
there's some breakthroughs the adaptive
lacing is a huge breakthrough you know I
was on the set of Back to the Future 30
30 years ago over 30 years ago and to
see that idea at that time now come to
reality and be available for everybody
is is really a dream it might be a dream
but why didn't need to make it a reality
in terms of Rd do we need that kind of
technology you crush it simply in terms
of air jordans well that's what we do we
always push the envelope this is all
about adaptive performance I think we're
gonna see more and more shoes and
products that have actually adapt with
you real time to help you perform at a
higher level when you talk about that
what is it what products do you think we
really need because right now we've seen
retail get slaughtered
China slow down but your China orders
only surge your numbers are great what
is it that you know that the rest of the
retail climate doesn't well it's all
about connecting with the athlete with
the consumer and when I say athlete I
mean all athletes global world-class
athletes to everyday athletes like you
and I I think a lot of ways and I'm
talking about Olympic level okay so the
the the important part is to connect
with the athletes and give them
something that they need and they want
and it could be something from a
performance standpoint that's critical
for them to perform at the highest level
but also something that aesthetically
puts them in the right frame of mind
that they feel good about it's
empowering those athletes who are women
you've said you want your women's
business to
in the next five years are you still on
track absolutely women's business for us
is incredibly important
women are more active today than ever
before that's not a trend it's a
movement and we expect that to continue
and we want to lead in that in that
respect you don't feel like it's a
catch-up oh cool because when we think
about women we often think names like
Lululemon we've seen you sever ties with
Maria Sharapova I'll just say that the
the women's opportunity for Nike is huge
and we're excited to be a part of
leading that that effort the opportunity
is huge but what are you doing what
results do you have that prove you're
getting there our business and the
women's side of the is growing at a much
faster clip than our men's business and
we expect that to continue it's a
smaller percentage of our business today
we expect that to outpace our men's
business for the foreseeable future
what's in store for this lifetime LeBron
contract because when we think
basketball right now I don't think Steph
Curry and you don't have stuff we don't
have stuff but we have some amazing
athletes I think we should not forget
the incredible athletes that Nike has a
range of athlete across all sports very
happy with the athlete there they're
there what drives the inspiration the
insights that ultimately create the
innovation that drives the company do
you feel the temptation to go off the
athlete route we've seen with Kanye West
as excuse me we see what adidas is done
with Kanye Kanye is taking a stab at
Nike even you but many people say Kanye
West that's a marketing expense doesn't
affect their bottom line do you want to
stick with athletes well we're all about
athletes really our bottom line our core
is about athletes and again athletes is
not just the world-class athletes it's
all athletes so we may work with someone
like Kevin Hart for example who was here
yesterday an amazing athlete obviously
he's an entertainer and he's got energy
that's unbelievable so having him here
and being a part of this event to unveil
the innovation that we've got was
incredibly appropriate well you don't
have a favorite product if there's only
one product we could see today here what
should it be I would say the one that's
capturing the most attention is the
adaptive lacing the power lacing and the
gateway into the future of adaptive
performance that's a massive
breakthrough